[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue sur la
chaîne parlementaire dans audition
publique premier tour des législatives
hier et au vu des résultats la question
électorale cette semaine et la suivante
emmanuel macron disposera-t-il d'une
majorité absolue ou relative dimanche
soir prochain dans cette assemblée
nationale où nous sommes c'est le
suspense est l'enjeu peut-il même perdre
la majorité tout court ce n'est pas le
plus vraisemblable mais en tout cas son
principal adversaire jean luc mélenchon
entretient la flamme et pour les autres
forces politiques de l'assemblée ait
l'air quoique très affaibli
deviendra-t-elle la force pivot
indispensable pour faire voter les
textes pour une majorité macro nist qui
serait reconduite marine le pen
parviendra-t-elle à faire élire un
groupe dont elle prendrait la présidence
qui serait pour elle évidemment un
succès même si
le rassemblement national qui a fait 42
% au deuxième tour de la présidentielle
restera marginale à l'assemblée rappelle
un rappel l'abstention record ce mal
français qui est aussi d'ailleurs un
mâle européen personne encore n'a où
trouver l'antidote à ce malaise
démocratique on pourra en parler ce soir
avec nos invités seront 4 4 élus lr
aimait les filles aient l'air et à
rennes dans l'assemblée sortante ils
disposent chacun de même temps de parole
pour revenir sur les leçons de ce
scrutin c'est parti et chaque fois yves
thréard plantera le décor bonsoir mon
frère et
tous directeur adjoint du figaro yves
thréard on va commencer par la majorité
dans un instant avec notre invité roland
berger majorité qui totalité un nombre
de qui a totalisé pardon un nombre de
voix important 25 75% beaucoup moins qu
emmanuel macron néanmoins en 2017 est ce
qu'ils les possibles dans l'ain les
jours qui restent de rectifier le tir et
d'obtenir une majorité absolue pour le
parti néo manuel macro est ce que c'est
encore jouable oui c'est encore jouable
évidemment mais c'est toute la question
qui se pose effectivement entre ces deux
tours et je pense que la majorité
présidentielle et notamment le président
de la république doivent se mordre les
doigts de ne pas avoir fait campagne
parce qu'en fait ils n'ont pas fait
campagne et le président de la
république a tout fait pour que
justement eh bien il n'y ait pas de mot
d'ordre et qu'on ne parle pas trop de
cette élection législative alors
aujourd'hui effectivement la question
est de savoir est ce que cette majorité
qui skie qui sera qui existera est ce
qu'elle sera absolue absolue avec les
alliés du parti du président quel parti
renaissance c'est à dire avec le modem
et avec horizon le parti le nouveau
parti de edouard philippe roux ça sera
une majorité relative aux quelqu'un si
c'est une majorité relative est bien là
la majorité présidentielle sera obligé
d'aller chercher des voix et notamment
peut-être au parti républicain sur sa
droite ce qui est sûr c'est que si c'est
une majorité relative se posera
nécessairement la question de
la première ministre ce que madame
elisabeth bornes qui est elle même
candidate dans le calvados et bien
pourra continuer à piloter ce
gouvernement et il y aura aussi
nécessairement des aménagements dans ce
gouvernement parce qu'on sait que pas
mal de ministres et bien sont en
ballottage très défavorable notamment
madame montchalin dans l'essonne pour le
deuxième tour est une autre question qui
se pose c'est de savoir si la majorité
présidentielle eh bien on va vouloir que
va vouloir prononcer un front
républicain vis-à-vis de ses électeurs
pour le deuxième tour c'est à dire
est-ce que et ça c'est très c'est pas
très clair dans l'esprit du public est
ce que il faut voter contre leur
rassemblement national mais est-ce qu'il
faut aussi ne pas voter pour
l'alliance l'union de la gauche
écologique et sociale et ça ce n'est pas
très clair est ce qu'il ya un front
républicain que la majorité
présidentielle de l'installer raison ce
n'est pas très clair on tentera d'en
savoir plus avec laurent berger dans un
instant merci frère à tout à l'heure
bien sûr oran berger bonsoir mais soir
vous êtes en bonne position apparemment
pour conserver votre siège dans la 10e
circonscription
des yvelines souffler la droite
conservatrice déjà il ya cinq ans je dis
bien parti mais une élection gagnée par
l'ong vous obtenez plus de 3 3% contre
22 % à votre adversaire nuxe cédric
briolet mais d'abord revenons à la
situation nationale avant que brigitte
boucher boucher ne vous pose toutes les
questions
sur cette élection à sujet de curiosité
quand même bien j'ai pas un mot pas un
seul mot du chef de l'état depuis le
vote des français par en roumanie en
moldavie et demain après le conseil des
ministres ça ne m'intéresse pas ce
second tour je crois qu'il s'est d'abord
exprimé avant le premier tour pour
redire très clairement aux français
qu'ils avaient besoin d'une majorité
d'une majorité donc absolue pour agir je
pense qu'il aura l'occasion de le redire
évidemment cette semaine c'est qu'il est
présent de la république et qu'il exerce
par ailleurs la présidence aussi l'union
européenne ce qui impose aussi un
calendrier qui est parfois un peu
contraint je ne doute pas qu'il dire
très clairement la nécessité que nos
électeurs se remobilise plus qu'ils ne
l'ont fait au premier tour de cette
élection législative de manière très
claire on a eu une forme de
démobilisation en tout cas une
mobilisation insuffisante rien venir et
que pour l'instant nous devons améliorer
sa fiche sur emmanuel macron un moment
parce que brigitte flahaut poser toutes
les questions sur les scrutins mais il
semble le président avoir du mal à
organiser la riposte c'est le sentiment
qu'on a il est il est aujourd'hui il ya
un enjeu majeur pour lui c'est d'obtenir
une majorité il n'a pas dit un mot il a
fait déjà une campagne en pointillés
précédemment il va prendre la parole
vous nous le dites ce soir pense qu'il
s'exprimera évidemment c'est ce que je
vais tendre on sent le souhaite et je
pense qu'en effet c'est indispensable
parce que le président de la république
à partir du moment où les élections
législatives ont lieu après l'élection
présidentielle est évidemment celui qui
est un moment donne l'impulsion
nécessaire et définitive pour mobiliser
notre électorat donc on fait panier
assez d'une nécessité qu'ils puissent
évidemment s'exprimer comme il l'a fait
avant le premier tour pour marteler
l'enjeu qui est celui de ce scrutin une
majorité pour le président de la
république un risque de majorité
relative avec donc ce risque
d'instabilité voire pire
le risque d'une majorité pour l'extrême
gauche dans notre pays brive et bush s
est un mot valise avait devancé par
aurore bergé vous êtes au coude à coude
avec la nuque quand on regarde les
résultats d'hier soir c'est l'alliance
de toute la gauche et on voit aussi que
vous perdez trois points par rapport au
score d'emmanuel macron premier tour de
l'élection présidentielle est-ce que
vous avez été désavoué par les électeurs
je pense pas qu'on puisse parler de
désaveu déjà parce qu il faudra regarder
surtout le second tour c'est-à-dire la
capacité qu'on a envoyé des
parlementaires des députés à l'assemblée
nationale et à former du coup cette
fameuse majorité d'un avertissement là
quand même qu'on vous a joué à dresser
oui lui je pense qu'il faut le prendre
comme tel un avertissement sur la
nécessité de se mobiliser de démontrer
qu'on est en campagne matin midi et soir
en campagne sur le terrain en campagne
aussi médiatique pour porter les
messages qui sont les nôtres sur
l'urgence à agir et agir vite sur les
questions essentielles sur les questions
de pouvoir d'achat sur les questions de
santé sur la transition écologique et
puis on a aussi une clarté finalement
dans cette élection on avait une clarté
dans la campagne présidentielle avec
deux blocs qui s'affrontaient et là on a
deux autres blocs aujourd'hui qui
s'affrontent la majorité présidentielle
et l'extrême gauche moi qui a eu des
facto une atonie disparition d'un
certain nombre d'autres formations vous
dites il faut montrer aux français qu on
fait campagne est-ce que ça a été
l'erreur finalement de cette campagne
d'avant premier tour de ne pas avoir
fait assez campagne nous on l'a fait sur
le terrain manière évidente sont à 577
candidats qui se sont déployées on à 421
candidats qui sont qualifiés pour le
second tour et qui donc les campagnes
nationales pour jouer seul ou
d'élisabeth avec un emmanuel macron
quillan très tardivement en campagne et
en même temps on a senti nous sur le
terrain que juste après l'élection
présidentielle avait une forme de
faillite des électeurs qui n'avaient pas
envie qu'on reparte immédiatement
campagne et qu'on les remous dierry jean
luc mélenchon finalement ça a fonctionné
c'est à fonctionner sur une fable ça a
fonctionné sur un mensonge cette fameuse
élection du premier ministre et on voit
bien quand même au soir un joli et
politique ne pourra pas non mais est ce
que jean luc mélenchon est habile
politiquement j'en ai jamais douté et en
effet il le prouve à nouveau certes la
question c'est que au delà de l'habileté
politique du coup politique c'est quel
est le discours de jean luc mélenchon et
quel est le projet surtout qu'il défend
et defacto la manière avec laquelle il a
asphyxié les autres formations
politiques de gauche qui ont renoncé à
des éléments qui étaient des éléments de
principes qu'ils avaient pourtant
défendu de manière assez acharné pendant
la campagne présidentielle de cette
alliance elle tient et jean luc
mélenchon président est le sien de
kenmore et la premier ministre vous vous
y croyez il peut encore être premier
ministre croit absolument pas je n'ai
jamais cru qu'il puisse l'être et je ne
crois pas qu'il pourrait l'être c'est
pas le sens de nos institutions c'est
pas notre mode de fonctionnement et
aujourd'hui c'est vrai qu'on a plutôt
deux éventualités soit une majorité
absolue soit une majorité relative pour
vous l'option d'une majorité absolue
pour jean luc mélenchon aujourd'hui au
regard du nombre de candidats qualifiés
me semble heureusement vous venez en
2017 la majorité donc la république en
marche à l'époque qui n'était pas
majorité avait obtenu était en tête dans
quatre circonscriptions et finalement
vous finissez avec un peu plus de 300 le
rapport de force il peut éventuellement
complètement s'inverser là où des
siècles dans un second tour c'est une
autre campagne qui s'ouvre parce que on
passe parfois de configuration vous
aviez 10 12 14 candidats voire plus
qualifiés aux pharaons candidats sur un
scrutin législatif à deux il ya très peu
de triangulaires il y en a 8 cette année
on avait une seule en 2010 est donc il
ya vraiment que des duels aujourd'hui
qui existent mais le sujet encore une
fois c'est le projet politique qui est
porté la force que nous nous avons c'est
que le projet politique que l'on porte
il est le même depuis la campagne
présidentielle à ce que dit jean luc
mélenchon encore une fois hier soir il
pêcha parole jay et idy il ya un projet
caché d'augmentation de la tva va la
corse en revenir à notre fonction
déficit vous avez un projet caché bien
sûr que non ça c'est le nouveau sujet
c'est la nouvelle tentative de jean luc
mélenchon il ya plusieurs tentatives
depuis hier soir 1 les résultats ne me
plaisent pas donc il dit que les
résultats sont truquées ce qui est quand
même un vrai problème dans la vie
démocratique de remettre alors il
s'appuie aussi j'ai eu quelques unes des
journalistes du monde ça lui donne
évidemment un argument supplémentaire et
extérieurs etc à son discours et c'est
amusant mais enfin je trouve même plus
amusant je trouve ça dangereux parce que
les candidats qui remettent en cause les
résultats d'une élection démocratique on
en a connu d'autres dans d'autres
démocraties et ça c'est pas forcément
bien fini qu'en regard notamment aux
états unis il parle notamment d'un
candidat monsieur ratenon qui actuel
député en disant il n'est pas
comptabilisé ça tombe bien en fait quand
on regarde les candidats investis par
nubes il est même pas sur leur site
internet aucun moment où il a siégé avec
eux dans le dans l'aube il investit pas
là semblent annoncer qu'elle a ça
voudrait dire que nous on comptabilise
aussi par exemple les dissidents divers
centres se sont présentés qu'on les
agglos mais la réponse est non donc un
nounours et que c'est quoi le pourrons
cette stratégie là mais c'est le
compresser le progrès rentabilité encore
une fois qu'ils aient porté aussi par un
avion lisztien bousculer déstabiliser
les institutions et de dire qu'il fait
des quelques mâles se sert du moment où
les résultats ne lui plaisent pas eh
bien ça veut dire que les enfants car
comment sont truquées et montrent qu'ils
avaient attaqué les sondages juste avant
le premier tour en disant que les
sondages le sous-estiment est
vraisemblablement d'ailleurs les
sondages l'avait surestime n 2 3 points
il pourrait peut-être les remercier au
lieu de les attaquer et puis des faits
que nous en effet il nous avait fait le
même coup pendant la campagne
présidentielle sur l'apprentissage nous
avait dit qu'on voulait quasiment retour
données du phare faire en sorte que les
enfants puissent à nouveau travailler
dans notre pays tout simplement parce
qu'on voulait pouvoir rien gardians delà
de campagne à al shouka pour le second
tour s'est attaqué jean luc mélenchon et
mérite sur son programme mais c'est à
dire la vérité à la fois sur les
mensonges qui sont les siens non nous
n'augmentons évidemment pas la tva celui
qui veut augmenter les taxes et crée
même 30 taxes nouvelles il s'appelle
jean luc mélenchon ça c'est leur route
sur les résistances les reports de
clément bonne soutient les candidats de
la nuque face aux arènes vous vous
préconisez courant dans ce cas de figure
deux choses simples c'est ce que
disaient aussi la porte parole du
gouvernement aujourd'hui un évidemment
aucune voix ne doit aller au
rassemblement national jamais jamais
nous n'appellerons à voter pour un
candidat du rassemblement national et
donc de l'extrême-droite vous appeler à
voter la nuance 8 dans les cas précis où
il y à des duels c'est à dire 58 cas où
il ya des duels entre le rassemblement
national
et là nous pèse est ce que pour autant
ça veut dire qu'il faut appeler à voter
pour les candidats d'extrême gauche
vient la question elle se pose en
fonction des candidats qui sont prises
donc ses biens au cas par cas en
fonction du profil du candidat nous
écouter et 2e dan front républicain en
fait mais j'ai ensemble on ne l'appliqué
pas le front républicain on peut avoir
un front républicain avec des candidats
qui par exemple ont caillassé la police
est ce qu'on peut avoir un front
républicain avec des candidats qui
rompent avec nos propres valeurs
républicaines alors évidemment quand il
s'agit de valérie rabault quand il
s'agit de fabien roussel le choix il est
très simple parce qu'on a des désaccords
d'idées mais on n'a pas de désarmer
prenait fondamentaux ou les voilà la
ligne
la ligne est un peu lisible on est entre
les mains et vous par exemple il ya déjà
une nuance mais je crois que la ligne en
tout cas qui a été celle du parti
politique est le mien ne dira pas une
voix rassemblement national mais en cas
de duel est ce que pas une voix
rassemblement national ça doit être
carrément de voter en faveur de
l'extrême gauche y compris des candidats
qui attaquent les forces de l'ordre y
compris des candidats qui rompent avec
nous sur les valeurs républicaines et
laïques y compris des candidats qui
honnêtement sur lesquelles on les droits
des femmes ne sont pas au niveau
la réponse elle ne peut pas être
automatique et on doit évidemment
regarder qui sont ses cordes souvenez
vous quand même depuis le début des
candidats investis par la nouvelle on a
eu quand même un certain nombre de
surprises quand on a regardé leur
parcours laurent saint martin il est
quand même par exemple fasse un candidat
qui a dit sur un plateau de télévision
au chili tout le monde garde est plus
compliqué de
la nouvelle assemblée oui la nouvelle
assemblée selon donc les estimations
qu'on a aujourd'hui vous pourriez avoir
une majorité plutôt relative qu'absolu
plus de chance en tout cas de majorité
relative est donc un peu plus de mal à
appliquer le programme qui est celui du
président de la république est ce que si
vous voulez faire passer un certain
nombre de réformes vous pourriez
éventuellement vous tourner vers les
républicains pour bâtir une coalition un
accord de gouvernement mais moi ce que
je dis d'abord à nos électeurs ce qu'ils
ont fait qu emmanuel macron a été
qualifié au second tour de l'élection
présidentielle s'est mobilisée vous pour
que nous puissions avoir cette majorité
a mais si vous ne l'avez pas au moins un
jour une coalition que je me bats pour
que cette majorité puisse exister pour
qu'une majorité absolue existe parce
qu'une majorité relative ça n'est pas
une majorité dans la vie parlementaire
française ça n'est pas vrai patron envie
de conclure un accord en tout cas avec
la république mais sur quelle base
électorale sur castres eu un accord de
gouvernement ça se fait mais ça veut
dire que ceux-ci manuellement avec
souvent parlé coalition à l'allemande ce
sont les seuls moments où ça il ya des
projets de loi qu'on a voté avec des
majorités plus large que seulement la
majorité qui était la nôtre et tant
mieux ça veut dire qu'on a réussi à
rallier en fonction des thématiques en
fonction des sujets parfois des
parlementaires et leur voir aussi
parfois des parlements d'euros vous vous
ayez d'euros au cas par cas sur certains
mais avoue que je veux avec les salines
pourquoi pas avec les aléas ce que je
veux c'est qu'on ait une majorité parce
que ce que je crois c'est que le projet
qu'on a porté pendant l'élection
présidentielle est un projet qui est
nécessaire encore une fois avec
l'urgence à agir sur venir
concessionnels ce projet il ya une
réforme qui est la retraite à 65 ans
est-ce que vous maintiendrez cette
réforme est est ce que si vous n'avez
pas la majorité absolue vous la ferez
passer alors être 20 secondes pour
répondre à cette question très
importante altorfer nous accorde t pour
financer nos retraites pour passer une
retraite minimale à 1100 euros donc elle
est prioritaire qu'elle sera votée mais
mme lagarde devra avoir une majorité
absolue qu'ils fassent qu'on n'ait pas
besoin mais si vous l'avez quitté ce
type d'outil mais je pense qu'on aura
une majorité absolue donc merci beaucoup
merci brigitte merci beaucoup à robert g
d'avoir été sur le plateau de lcp ce
soir dans son édition public avant de da
cueillir danièle obono pour la nuque
on se retrouve évidemment avec yves
thréard avec lequel on plante le décor à
chaque fois que nous accueillons un
nouvel invité yves quelles sont les
caractéristiques que vous avez relevé de
ce vote nuxe du premier tour des
législatives
bon d'abord il faut rendre à césar ce
qui est à césar il ya eu cinq députés
qui ont été élus dès le premier tour à
l'occasion de cette élection législative
du premier tour et bien il y en a quatre
des cinq qu'ils viennent justement de
cette nouvelle union populaire
écologique et sociale et 4 dont madame
obono d'ailleurs qui est élue à paris et
comme madame shihri coup également où
monsieur alexis corbière alors
aujourd'hui la question qui se pose
c'est de savoir si et bien monsieur
mélenchon pourra devenir premier
ministre je crois que on peut déjà dire
que il ne sera pas premier ministre
parce que la majorité n'ira pas à cette
nuxe en revanche cette nuxe pourrait
très bien si elle arrive à être le
premier groupe d'opposition à
l'assemblée nationale eh bien obtenir la
présidence de la commission des finances
et ça ce n'est pas rien parce que c'est
un pouvoir qui est un pouvoir très
important qui est donné à l'opposition
et puis l'autre question qui se posera
c'est de savoir si cette alliance qui a
été fait avec monsieur mélenchon qui ne
sera pas d'ailleurs à l'assemblée
nationale puisqu'il n'est pas candidat
aux législatives
et bien si cette alliance sera
suffisamment solides pour tenir parce
qu'on sait très bien qu'il ya beaucoup
de sujets qui divisent
les insoumis d'avec les écologistes
d'avec des socialistes aidé avec les
communistes c'est va tout à l'heure
bonsoir danièle obono vous faites partie
de cette poignée de députés en
l'occurrence souhaite d'ailleurs députée
sortante avoir été élus désirent soir
félicitations vous êtes réélu dans la
10e circonscription de paris 7e j'ai dix
points en septième j'ai dit dix septième
et dix septième circonscription de paris
c'est bien sa part dont
le pari gagné pour vous on va parler du
résultat national de paris agnés aussi
d'une certaine façon mais pas au point
d'obtenir une majorité absolue pour
l'instant d'après les projections jean
luc mélenchon ne serait pas prévenu
c'est une déception mais il ya encore un
deuxième tour donc peut-être que nous
pouvons attendre que le peuple souverain
dans cette élection le décide ou pas et
votent ce dimanche donc ne sont pas les
projections ne sont pas le résultat et
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas c'est pas le
moment du vote non nous nous sommes
plutôt satisfaits du premier tour qui a
vu tout de même près de 400 candidats et
candidates soutenu par la nouvelle union
populaire accéder au second tour nous
mêmes nous sommes quatre à être élu dès
le premier tour c'est
aujourd'hui quand même une excellente
nouvelle et nous pensons que nous avons
les réserves de voix dans la jeunesse
dans les classes populaires on ne vient
pas mobilisés c'est une question pour
vous en restez mans et que l'objectif
reste effectivement d'être majoritaire
parce que le pays en a besoin et nous
avons un programme de gouvernement qui
répondent aux urgences du moment tam
trân minh d'auditions publiques de
public sénat vous interroge mâcon soir
elisabeth bon soeur danièle obono on va
parler tout d'abord cette querelle de
chiffres autour du premier tour la nulle
part revendiqué la victoire du premier
tour de ces élections avec 26 points 8 %
des voix ce n'est pas ce que dit le
ministère de l'intérieur il vous donne
25 66% des pouvoirs et vous fait donc
passer derrière ensemble alors on a déjà
entendu un certain dans votre camp parlé
de manipulation est ce que tout
simplement vous n'avez pas parlé trop
vite non je pense que l'expérience des
derniers mois a montré à quel point le
ministère de l'intérieur était très
fébrile avec d'abord la nomination de
notre alliance il a fallu aller devant
le conseil d'état tout de même qui a
intimé au ministère de reconnaître notre
nouvelle union populaire las nubes donc
on a là encore une stratégie
politicienne de trèbes à
cette stratégie c'est un choix c'est un
choix politique du ministère de
l'intérieur il en est en charge et le
ministère de l'intérieur 1 et vous dis
au contraire que vous n'aviez investi
personnes en outre mer que vous
revendiquez aujourd'hui des candidats en
métropole que vous ne vive donc illégaux
on sait ça ici la corne concernés par
des pairs oui mais l'accord ne
concernait pas les huîtres mères
l'accord de la nuit mais ce sont des
candidats et comme date que nous
soutenons officiellement oui mais qu'ils
servent que tarik nom et qui s'en
revendiquent je pense que karine le bon
par exemple qui est au premier tour qui
est au second tour et qu'il a dit a
interpellé le ministère en demandant à
être comptés comme les sommes comme de
la nouvelle union populaire donc
effectivement cet accord ne concerne
mais nous les soutenons officiellement
et quand on voit par exemple la manière
dont le ministère de l'intérieur a
inscrit des députés d'outre-mer comme
étant des soutiens ou alors même des
dissidents mais ne fait pas la même pour
nous on voit bien qu'il ya une tactique
le milieu extérieur par exemple de
kabylie spa maintenant battre comme
candidats ensemble ni marie luce
penchard qui pourtant est elle même
soutenue par la majorité présidentielle
loyer donc à un choix politique donc ça
n'a rien à l'homme et sanitaires
objectif mais dont vous parlez le parler
de manipulation vous entendez que
évidemment les veuves ou désavantagé
mais là ils viennent saper concerne
aussi des zébrés ma question mais c'est
le choix qui est fait griller ce qui
fait le choix c'est le ministère de
l'intérieur qui les déclarations qui
sont faites par elle a brillé elle qui a
la tête de du ministère de l'intérieur
monsieur darmanin qui a déjà été pris la
main dans le sac par le conseil d'état
donc oui c'est une mouture colère pour
les tic pour le bayer a de nouveau
requis voix nous y réfléchissons on
verra s'il est besoin et s'il est
nécessaire de le faire mais si je me
rappelle bien recollé à une évaluation
masse à ma question précis parce qu'on a
plein de questions vous posez daniel
bonheur parce que vous êtes maintenant
tu vraiment coeur du sujet mais si une
manipulation ce que vous dites ce que
jean luc mélenchon a laissé entendre ce
matin fail a dit non et pas mais une
opération mais enfin quand même il doute
j'allais vous allez au conseil d'état
c'est évident si vous n'allez pas vous
allez passer que vous n'êtes pas sur
quelle manipulation nous allons des
sous-entendus nous allons étudier la
question comme nous l'avions fait
précédemment en vérifiant exactement
quels critères a choisi et quels sont
les justifications données d'ailleurs
par le ministère et on fera les
démarches qu'il faut mais on voyait la
turquie un salaire mais si il ya un
problème est important que nous prenons
le temps de faire les choses
sérieusement parce que c'est une
question sérieuse si nous avons
interpellé c'est que nous considérons
effectivement que en reprenant
politiquement les choix qui sont faits
par la nouvelle union populaire de
soutien nous en tête et ce n'est pas
anodin effectivement que le ministère de
l'intérieur monsieur darmanin veuille
nous faire apparaître comme second dont
nous ferons les démarches que nous
estimons nécessaire on tend vers
on va essayer de se projeter vers le
second tour où se trouve aujourd'hui vos
réserves de voix mais comme je les dis
alors d'abord sais pas c'est pas un
réservoir qui sur lesquels pc des
bâtiments nous on s'adresse d'abord à
l'ensemble de la population et de tous
les électeurs et les électrices il faut
il s'agit de s'assurer que celles et
ceux qui sont déjà allés voter
reviennent ce dimanche et puis bien
entendu toutes celles des millions de
français et françaises qui se sont ne se
sont pas rendus aux urnes donc notamment
dans la jeunesse
oui et ça toujours été d'ailleurs notre
stratégie y compris à la présidentielle
où nous avions vu dans de nombreux
quartiers populaires des primo votants
et vos tentes qui sont venus parce que
nous avions fait ce travail assez léché
et donc là c'est l'échec quand même
lorsque vous voyez l'abstention louis
alors j'ai dit aux garçons mais c'est un
échec collectif je vous rappelle tout de
même que jusqu'à 2016 si le vôtre non
non attendez il est maintenant il ya des
responsabilités quand même au niveau de
l'état jusqu'à 2016 l'état mener des
campagnes pour rappeler les campagnes
nationales avec des spots publicitaires
avec de l'incident mais aujourd'hui il
n'en fait plus il a choisi de ne plus en
faire donc c'est une première
responsabilité et après nous nous avons
fait notre travail nous avons milité sur
le terrain nous avons fait des caravanes
pour la réinscription sur les listes
électorales mais à notre niveau nous
n'avons pas les moyens de l'état encore
une fois monsieur darmanin la devrait
peut-être répondre à quelques questions
à ce niveau là et puis bien sûr
l'abstention tarn à 9 ans maintenant il
attend là
évidemment nos responsabilités on voit
là on voit la manière dont il gère tout
cela de du stade de france juste poser
les comprennent et la question en
instance ionis etc il ya quand même
aussi les électeurs rassemblement
national qui vont certainement faire la
victoire au deuxième tour est ce que
vous vous adressez à eux est ce que vous
leur tendez la main aussi nous nous
adressons comme je le dis à tout le
monde nous voulons convaincre le maximum
de français et françaises que c'est avec
la nouvelle union populaire qu'ils
obtiendront le blocage des prix pour
faire face aux conditions de vie et au
pouvoir d'achat qui s'est écroulé depuis
depuis des mois pour faire face
aujourd'hui aux problématiques de
changement climatique nous voulons
convaincre toute la population autour
des langues le paye ne s'agit pas il
s'agit par là on n'a cessé de répéter un
ce matin que jean luc mélenchon était un
menteur envoyé beaucoup de bruit mais
écoutez elle fait elle fait sa politique
politicienne depuis 40 ans elle a hérité
de sa pme sa pme de son père et on voit
bien en fait les cinq dernières années
ont montré à quel point elle était
inutile à l'assemblée nationale elle ne
veut pas être majoritaire salue qu'on
voit très bien de passer encore cinq ans
sous emmanuel macron parce que alice
elle espère à nouveau être au 2e tour
donc ça n'a rien à voir effectivement
elle ne veut rien changer elle veut que
tout reste pareil pour continuer à
profiter du site à l'est entre nous 40
d'opposante tout à fait tout à fait
réelle et réelles a dit d'ailleurs très
clairement elle elle considère que
monsieur emmanuel macron tu dois avoir
une majorité elle l'a dit jean rède
laura est la logique des sélections bref
lui est par ailleurs nous ne considérons
pas l'électorat comme des parts de
marché nous considérons que tous les
français et françaises qui ont le droit
de vote doivent pouvoir se prononcer sur
les faits sur le programme nous sommes
les seuls à avoir proposé un programme
qui est chiffrée après on le dit on n'en
veut pas ou pas on essaie d'ailleurs le
siège et oui oui bon d'accord mais je
vous rappelle tout de même que c'est le
seul à avoir été l'objet d'autant de ce2
d'attention parce qu' il existe en fait
il ya 170 économistes qui soutient ce
programme nous sommes basés sur les
évaluations de la banque de france donc
c'est sérieux et nous nous voulons
convaincre tout le monde que aujourd'hui
pour l'avenir du pays ça peut changer
dimanche il ya déjà ce que nous avons
fait et assez historique et
les électeurs les électrices tiennent
dans leurs mains le destin du pays alors
une question précisément sur la question
du blocage de laiterie est ce que vous
ne craignez pas les pénuries puisque il
ya quand même besoin aussi de ce signal
prix pour produire alors comme même que
nous sommes dans une période d'inflation
qui est extrêmement importante et
surtout est-ce que c'est pas une mesure
trop large qui va bien pour le coup aux
favoris lors des hausses il est plus
aisé de la même alors d'abord est-ce que
ça pénalise les entreprises tous les
économistes que d'autres aux économistes
que les 10 attention ça forcément un
blocage des prix et c'est logique un
enfant pourrait comprendre ça ça va
pénaliser les entreprises et la deuxième
question en effet ce que c'est pas trop
large donc d'abord nous nous avons
expliqué à quel niveau se faisait le
blocage et où est ce que nous prenions
la marche chez les producteurs chez ceux
et celles par exemple dans
l'agroalimentaire qui sont en charge de
la distribution et qui se font les plus
je parlais parler excusez moi je le
précise les producteurs au niveau de
l'énergie par exemple total a fait les
plus gros bénéfices de toute son
histoire donc cela je vous assure que
ils seront alors ça c'est les chances
mais y'a pas que les sages et elle ne
gagnera exemple sur le panier sur les
les grandes enseignes de distribution
qui y compris ont commencé à faire ce
travail donc vous voyez que c'est tout à
fait possible donc non nous prendrons
les marges où elles existent parce qu'à
où beaucoup déjà par exemple mais parce
qu'on n'est pas adroit avec ma mère
aujourd'hui les grandes enseignes ont
fait énormément de profits pendant la
crise est longue il s'agit tout
simplement fait de réduire l on le dit
on réduit le coefficient multiplicateur
qui permet et comment que les enseignes
ne reporte pas ce que vous le reprenez
sur les prix et
sur les indices us pour le blog s'est
passé
on intervient au niveau du coefficient
multiplicateur et ya un article du code
de commerce qui permet cela justement
oui ça c'est le temps il est par
ailleurs ce que vous disiez sur plus
largement d'abord on n'a pas dit que ce
sera surtout on compte bien s'appuyer
sur ce qui existe pas déjà par exemple à
la réunion où il ya une conservation de
deux heures des produits de première
nécessité et vous êtes alors que
s'affairent valait bien tout le monde y
compris les plus aisés oui mais par
ailleurs nous ce qu'on met en avant l'
ce sont des mesures d'urgence mais on va
aussi faire en sorte par exemple que
l'impôt soit plus progressif et qui
permette meilleure audi frise tribution
donc là ce sont des premières mesures et
nous ferons en sorte y compris sur la
tva qui est un des plus injustes
effectivement dans nos mesures vous
l'avez vu un énième livre d'ailleurs la
transition non non aux coups de taxes à
dia non non non non il ya de la
progressivité ce qui est pour le coup
une réponse de justice fiscale
absolument nécessaire qu'il a promis la
taxation pour ceux qui ont beaucoup et
il ya mois pour ceux qui ont justement
moi les classes moyennes ne paieront
mais perd au moins à leur guano 4000 ont
une dernière question sur l'avenir de la
nuit puisque c'est la question quand
même que tout le monde se pose est ce
que c'est une simple unité de
circonstance un pour maximiser votre
score à ce scrutin ou est ce qu'il ya
vraiment un avenir quand on voit par
exemple peut-il y avoir une unité
lorsqu'on voit que lorsque jean luc
mélenchon a déclaré la police tue
immédiatement fabien roussel le chef du
pcf a dit je ne ferai jamais d'un
amalgame en dix ans la police tu es ce
que l'unité ce n'est pas juste une
façade je pense que réduire à cela les
650 petit sans mesure non mais c'est
majeur c'est arrivé elle est maintenant
ce qui est majeur c'est le programme de
gouvernement nous nous sommes engagés
devant les français et les françaises -
de douter de l'engagement aussi réussi
sa soirée aux valeurs ont par leur nom
selon moi la seigneurie guérilla la
volaille importées dans notre programme
à danser dans ces mesures des mesures
régalienne de renforcement de la police
républicaine non mr d'extension de la
formation de perception oui mais est-ce
qu'on peut accepter le fait que nous
sommes d'accord et à moins de douter de
l'engagement vite que sur ussel sur le
programme qu'il a signé au nom que le
parti communiste a signé à vous en fais
douillet types de prix n'en donne un
rôle de nathan russe et je joins jour du
scrutin je ne doute pas de l'engagement
des communistes quand ils ont signé ce
papier devant les français et françaises
en dix ans c'est un accord de
normalement nous voulons gouverner et
nous sommes bien devrait bientôt sur 90
écoutez les communistes ne se résume
s'il vous plaît pas à monsieur roussel
mesure où celles d'autres c'est vrai
parti communiste n'a une monsieur
roussel à différentes approches et
encore encore heureux que nous ayons des
approches différentes on nous a
suffisamment critique est en effet que
nous étions des petits soldats derrière
jean-luc mélenchon pour apprécier quand
même que nous que nous assumions y
compris omettre la diversité ou la
poésie et on est uniquement nous avons
montré sur 99 % du programme nous sommes
d'accord mais il ya une partie sur
lesquels on a des approches différentes
et on serait suffisamment avait pour les
mettre en avant en effet c'est il me
circonstances c'est l'élection qui le
permet mais c'est sur la base d'un
programme fondamental et nous
envisageons gouverner donc l'objectif
c'est que ça se pérennise et nous
espérons bien si nous sommes
majoritaires et nous pensons que c'est
possible gouverner pendant cinq ans ce
préavis si et changer la vie des gens
merci beaucoup danièle obono d'avoir été
le temps passe vite avec nous dans un
instant bien sûr on reçoit maintenant
représentant l air sénateurs mais
d'abord il fera toujours pour introduire
notre invité yves alors focus sur sur la
leyre dans un instant comment s'en
sortent eut-il hausse après ce premier
tour des législatives
bah écoutez après la débâcle de la
présidentielle je trouve que cette
élection législative en tous les cas ces
premiers tours rétabli un peu je dirais
redonne un peu le moral aux troupes
aient l'air puisque il dépasse 10% ils
sont à 11% donc deux fois plus de deux
fois le score devrait pécresse à la
présidentielle ils perdent évidemment
des figures du parti comme monsieur
guillaume larrivé comme monsieur julien
aubert qui aspirait à des à des
fonctions à l'avenir donc il est
probable il est probable que le premier
parti d'opposition ne soit plus à
l'assemblée nationale les républicains
qui était quelques cents et bien là on
dit qu'il pourrait avec le deuxième tour
arrivait à être cinquante ou soixante
deux questions se posent la première des
questions est-ce que si il y à une
majorité relative en faveur du président
de la république
les républicains n'accepteront sur
certes texte qui leur convienne
c'est accepteront d'être une force
d'appoint c'est à dire de voter avec la
majorité présidentielle pour adopter les
textes deuxième chose dès dimanche là
dans les circonscriptions où les
républicains ne sont pas qualifiés où il
ya des matches entre nubes et ensemble
c'est à dire la majorité présidentielle
est-ce que et bien est-ce qu'il y aura
des consignes de votes des républicains
pour faire barrage à du ps voilà deux
questions passionnantes auquel vont
répondre roger karoutchi qu on est très
heureux de recevoir merci à vous
sénateur n'appartenant qu'on puisse en
des sénateurs a l'air le faux nez le
premier groupe à l'assemblée eh bien ma
foi il y avait douze 112 députés l air
il y en europe combien peut-être la
moitié au mieux vous avez évidemment
limité la casse roger karoutchi quand on
regarde le score de valérie pécresse
4,75 pour cent mais vous perdez des
forces est ce que vous pensez quand même
que l'assemblée nationale pour vous sera
encore un lieu où vous exercerez une
influence politique importante je pense
que oui d'abord parce que même si je
pense et je crois que emmanuel macron
nous fait sauter à la corde et qu'en
réalité il aura une majorité absolue il
aura une majorité absolue mais plus
étriquée que celle de 2017 c'est donc
plus difficile à tenir plus difficile à
gérer pour la suite et il regardera
forcément plus vernon groupe
parce que depuis quelques jours un peu
comme avant les présidentielles par
rapport à marine le pen depuis quelques
jours nous fait on nous dit oh là là non
non pas du tout il faut absolument voter
pour nous parce que nous n'aurons pas la
majorité absolue ça va être le désordre
mélenchon est aux portes bon il faut que
ça s'arrête a les chiffres montrent non
pas du tout pas du tout les tous ceux
qui font des projections à peu près
clair voit bien qu'en réalité ils sont
entre 290 et 320 alors
aucun doute quand on sait concerne les
projections la major et c'est après lui
est assuré c'est pour ça que je dis et
nous électeurs de droite ne vous
fatiguez pas à les donner à monsieur
macron une majorité qui l'a déjà qu'il
va et qu'on arrête un peu cette espèce
de deux de vote utile à anvers on nous a
fait le vote utile sur marine le pen
présidentielle ont fait le vote utile
sur mélangeant législatives si on
laissait les gens voter en fonction de
leurs convictions ça pourrait aider
alors peut-être qu'il y aura une
majorité absolue en tout cas le premier
groupe d'opposition devraient être là
elle est fille la france a soumis
l'accord nul alliance de toute la gauche
ça vous êtes d'accord ça veut dire quoi
ça veut dire que les républicains vont
perdre quand même des postes clefs à
l'assemblée nationale la présidence de
la commission des finances un poste de
questeur davis présidence de l'assemblée
vous allez être les invisibles de
l'assemblée
une approche pense pas qu'on sera les
invisibles d'autant que même si on a un
groupe de 60 par exemple d'un groupe de
100 pas par définition il faut que nos
députés soit plus actif que nos députés
soit très présent que nos députés soit
dans la proposition et ils ne seront pas
transparent vous savez le groupe et les
filles c'était 17 c'est plus de bruit
que tout le reste de l'hémicycle donc
s'il était sans justement donc vous
allez quand même la barre de la science
comme le disait qu'il avait perdu
pouvoir aussi ça veut dire aussi et
toujours du pouvoir ça on va voir ce qui
se passe avec le gouvernement et la
présidence de l'assemblée mois par vaux
qui décide c'est d'ailleurs pas
seulement les l ère où les 60 élèves qui
vont décider des équilibres internes à
l'assemblée nationale j'ai cru
comprendre mais c'est beau ce que dans
le règlement de pop up
on n'y croyait pas la présidence de la
commission des finances revient à un
membre de l'opposition
il n'y a pas écrit revient aux produits
que vous pensez que ça pouvait encore
revenir un république je n'enregistre
vous le souhaitez en tout cas le jeu de
souhaite de ryan je n'attendais rien est
ce que le sénat que vous représentez ce
soir est plus que jamais le bastion de
la droite et finalement le premier
opposant emmanuel macron nous n'avons
jamais été le premier opposant à qui que
ce soit parce que c'est pas une
conception au sénat
au sénat nous votons les textes quand
ils nous conviennent nous les amandons
où les transformant où l'airé étudions
mais nous ne sommes pas une force si
politisée que ça alors c'est vrai un
rôle de contre-pouvoir important vous
avez emmené des commissions bancaires
dont vous le politique non pardon de
vous dire on a joué le rôle du parlement
parce que le rôle du parlement c'est pas
seulement de voter la loi c'est de
contrôler l'action du gouvernement et
quand l'assemblée générale
contre-pouvoir quand l'assemblée
nationale renonce à faire ce job parce
qu au nom d'un principe de majorité
présidentielle vous y renoncer il faut
bien qu'ils aient une assemblée qu'il
fasse et c'est le sénat qui l'a fait et
qui continuera de le faire ça veut dire
quoi vous n'êtes pas des gaulois
réfractaires mais des irréductibles
gaulois je vous envoie passionné
on ne peut plus les irréductibles
gaulois que
paul était assiégée par qui nous sommes
majoritaires au sénat la sélection
nationale où elles errent encore un peu
de poids beaucoup de poids d'ailleurs
beaucoup pas seulement dans le berry
dans les conseils départementaux les
conseils régionaux finalement le seul
endroit où on n'est pas majoritaire et
où c'est l'assemblée nationale oui ce
qui par les temps où cela c'est que les
tifs
réduite par le pouvoir en place qui ne
considèrent pas beaucoup le parlement
c'est pas le lieu où se fait l'essentiel
des choses ça se fait plus en ce moment
niveau territorial et local qu'au niveau
national on a vu en tout cas pour la
campagne qui a été mené par les
républicains elle a pas été nationale a
été très territorialisée est ce que
pensait que c'était la meilleure
stratégie à mener
écoutez il faut quand même se dire les
choses
et c'est pas la faute de la candidate
mais enfin on a fait 4 78 aux élections
présidentielles qu'il fallait que
derrière
avec des thématiques les gens rigolaient
sauf que vous aviez 100 députés vous
aurez 50 p qu'est-ce qu'on aurait eu si
on leur avait imposé une hymne national
et si on n'avait pas été la bonne
stratégie moi je pense qu'il fallait
laisser nos candidats adaptés leur
campagne au terrain adapté leurs
campagnes aux conditions locales c'est
ce qu'ils ont fait alors on aurait dû on
aurait pu peut-être être un peu plus vif
sur ni mélenchon ni ma grand républicain
c'est ce que j'appelle une campagne
nationale voilà oui mais ça aurait été
du slogan il fallait pas rentrer dans le
détail des propositions ça en a l'air
vous misez sur l'ancrage local sur la
prime aux sortants ça a pas bénéficié à
tous à droite et notamment à julien
aubert c'est une perte importante pour
vous pas seulement lui tous ceux qui ont
perdu au premier tour ce sont des
jeux julien aubert et d'autres
républicains il voulait changer d un
rôle important je suis bien
c'est pas seulement qu'ils voulaient
jouer il avait un rôle important et il
ne paie ils continueront à avoir des
activités politiques qui ne sont plus
députés mais ils ont encore des
activités politiques à nous de
reconstruire autre chose alors il ya un
conseil national qui s'est tenu ce matin
chez les républicains stratégie comité
stratégique pardon et christian jacob le
patron des parties a dit pas une voix
aux extrêmes pour le second tour des
élections législatives c'est donc la
position du parti ça veut dire que vous
mettez un signe égal finalement entre
eux le rassemblement national et la
nuque pour vous c'est la même chose sont
les extrêmes où je n'ai pas que c'est la
même chose mais je dis que je n'ai pas
envie de voter ni pour les uns ni pour
les autres
moi par exemple d'un matière à réflexion
bas au deuxième tour on a une candidate
en marche enfin
qui est sortante et de l'autre côté une
candidate du ps je ne vous cache pas que
je voudrais évidemment pour la candidate
renaissance
appliquer le front républicain alors non
pas du tout je vous dis que
nulle si j'étais dans une circo où il y
avait ni ps est reine j'aurais bien
embarrassée parce que j'ai pas envie de
voter ni pour les uns ni pour les autres
dans ce cas il faut s'abstenir ses
salles à la con s'il n'y a pas de
consignes là chacun fera en conscience
mais n'eut père semble vous vous votez
chaque
maman je ne peux pas voter du ps
pouvait voter ensemble
bruno retailleau par exemple lui de
voter ensemble contre coeur parce que je
préfère est votée l air mais je préfère
même s'il en a pas besoin députés
supplémentaires à renaissance caleffi
supplément d'ibm alors les républicains
sont affaiblis on vient de le dire mais
paradoxalement vous pourriez jouer un
rôle important dans la nouvelle
assemblée si les estimations se
confirment dimanche prochain parce qu
emmanuel macron n'aura pas forcément
cette majorité absolue est ce que dans
ce cas vous seriez prêt à conclure un
accord de gouvernement à bâtir une vraie
coalition avec ensemble crois pas que ce
soit une bonne idée moi j'avais défendu
au comité stratégique mais déjà il ya
deux mois l'idée s'il n'y a pas de
majorité absolue ce que je ne crois pas
enfin si c'était le cas j'avais défendu
l'idée d'un contrat législatifs
c'est-à-dire de dire au gouvernement
rentre pas dans le gouvernement nous
restons dans l'opposition clairement de
manière déterminée mais si vous voulez
nous présenter des textes sur les
retraites sur un certain nombre de
sujets de sécurité sur des sujets liés
au pouvoir d'achat et que sur cette
thématique là on puisse discuter et
avancer pourquoi pas voilà c'est une
opposition sur un certain nombre de
sujets on n'arrivera pas d'accord donc
c'est même pas la peine mais ne pas ne
pas faire de l'opposition absolue c'est
ce que j'ai fait depuis cinq ans une
position constructive ça vous a pas
tellement réussi quand on regarde
valérie pécresse qui a dû régler pour
cent je suis pas sûr que ce soit le
bilan parlementaire qui est fait le
scrutin présidentiel non mais vous
pensez que vous vous démarquez
suffisamment un moment plus trop
finalement la frontière si vous êtes
prêts à voter des noms que le
gouvernement
au sénat on l'a toujours fait d'ailleurs
que ce soit un gouvernement de gauche ou
de droite comme le texte nous paraissait
convenable on l'a amendé et voter ça n'a
pas empêché l'air de rester majoritaires
au sénat donc c'est pas là dessus que
les choses se font malheureusement pour
la présidentielle il faut incarner il
faut qu'on trouve il faut qu'on trouve
pour les l air pour la suite une réforme
complète du parti sans excès j'entends
des choses où on disait à tout casser
non ils font reconstruire il faut
rénover un constat il faut par an par
pas dit à chaque fois qu'on les batte
une élection on nous a tout cassé à
droite franchement depuis le temps
hélas cette pratique serait de plus en
plus c'est pour ça qu'il faut qu'on
trouve un moyen on a écarté
définitivement les partenaires il faut
maintenant qu'on ait un candidat qui
veut y aller à la présidence du parti et
qui soit l'incarnation
moi je n'ai pas encore de candidat et
qui pourra l'être sur ya des vagues les
bernois n'ont appartient à 3,4 mais je
ne vais pas évoqué ce soir attendons le
de femmes jeu l'atvs au sol est une
femme ou un homme peu importe à
condition qu'il incarne végéta dernière
qu'elle s'appelait d'opposition
constructive christian jacob à parler
d'opposition utile tout à l'heure ça
veut dire quoi par exemple la première
loi du quinquennat qui serait une loi
sur le pouvoir d'achat il faut la voter
c'est bien pour les français mais
on a tendance à vouloir tout regarder
qu'on déjà eu des pointes à regarder le
sénat par exemple n'a pas dit non
d'office on va travailler sur les
propositions faire de contre
propositions et on peut voir si on
arrive à quelque chose mais il s'agit
pas de dire que parce que le
gouvernement propose lui une
amélioration du pouvoir d'achat des
français comme c'est le gouvernement va
dire non ce serait absurde et les
retraites vous évoquez est on l'a déjà
dit sur les 65 ans oui d'accord mais
que la cia les 66 que ces deux options
be avant
vu la composition de l'assemblée
aujourd'hui ça m'étonnerait ça vous
étonnerai que ça puisse être présentée
comme initialement parole emmanuel
macron dans sa conférence de presse il
va devoir amender ce type de projet
sentiment probablement et
le deuxième mandat il est clair que il
sera plus sensible à la rue et aux
pouvoirs de dollars et il y aura
forcément la rue ça va vous pensez que
là
ce ne sera pas fini la france s'est
fracturé la situation sociale est
calamiteuse la situation économique
n'est pas meilleure l'inflation est là
comment voulez vous qu'il n'y ait pas de
manifestation dans la rue donc c'est un
quinquennat chaotique chaotique j'en
sais rien difficile c'est sur un
quinquennat de crise encore à huy de
crise merci beaucoup angers karoutchi
président que vous pensiez qu'il aurait
une majorité peut vous pensez qu'il y
aura une rectification en fait au second
tour par rapport au premier temps c'est
ce que voulait non parce que si on fait
la projection exact on est entre 305 et
70 sièges pour
merci beaucoup roger karoutchi d'avoir
été avec nous ce soir merci
et dans un instant alors dernier parti
sur lequel on va faire un focus c'est le
rassemblement national manche et ribes
dernier invité votre intervention sur la
lecture du scrutin d'hier est ce qu
l'air anoraa un groupe à l'assemblée ce
qui serait quand même une première
depuis très longtemps c'est
effectivement elisabeth la grande
question de savoir si le rassemblement
national arrivera à 15 des petits
puisque c'est là la barre qu'il faut
franchir pour constituer un groupe c'est
très important parce que comme vous avez
un groupe à l'assemblée nationale eh
bien vous avez davantage de temps de
parole vous avez plus de pouvoir et vous
avez plus d'argent donc c'est s'est
considérablement important pour le
rassemblement national c'est la première
fois que rassemblement national après
une élection présidentielle arrive à
faire un score qui est tout à fait
honorable dans le cadre d'une élection
législative puisqu'on est autour de 19%
et c'est d'autant plus honorable que
avec le taux d'abstention qui est de
plus de 5 pour cent et bien c'est bon
pour le rassemblement national qui est
un parti où il ya beaucoup d'abstention
généralement parce que c'est un parti
qui vote où on vote beaucoup chez les
jeunes et chez dans les catégories les
plus modestes
alors ce qui sera intéressant de savoir
aussi c'est si madame le pen est bien en
temps jouer un rôle capital pour
l'avenir un rôle central au sein de son
parti et au sein du groupe à l'assemblée
nationale parce que elle nous a laissé
entendre qu'elle ne serait plus candidat
à l'élection présidentielle donc en 2027
sauf si sauf si et bien sûr si le
rassemblement national arrive à se faire
entendre précisément pendant le
quinquennat qui va s'ouvrir ces jours ci
vous avez raison c'est une question qui
reste en suspens on voit la poser à
notre invité andré acosta rac merci
beaucoup et très raide prochaine en vrac
au thorax merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes conseiller régional rhône alpes
porte parole du rnd porte parole ancien
militant de l'efi c'est vrai que c'est
une de vos singularité
revenant d'un mot sur cette victoire en
demi-teinte une victoire oui parce que
jamais et c'est un score important
jamais le rassemblement national n'a
réalisé un score aussi important premier
tour des législatives des 19% de mémoire
et pourtant vous resterez néanmoins
marginalisés d'une certaine façon à
l'ombre des autres partis et l'air
lannux est
ensemble est ce que est ce que vous ne
restez pas fondamentalement un parti pas
comme les autres qu'ils n'arrivent pas à
passer un cran aux élections locales et
or or élections nationales
présidentielle fait raison c'est un
record à nouveau comme notre résultat
aux présidentielles l'était aussi plus
de 13 millions d'électeurs ont porté
leurs voix sur marine le pen mais
fondamentalement quand on analyse
vraiment ces résultats des législatives
en réalité le premier parti de france
c'est le rassemblement national pourquoi
parce que quand on parle d'ensemble et
des maquereaux nice il ya le parti
horizon est à le parti algeria le parti
allait re aiment tout un tas d'autres
partis et puis chez lannux c'est ce
fameux cartel de l'armée mexicaine où en
réalité ne sont pas d'accord sur le
nucléaire et sur la politique
énergétique ne sont pas d'accord sur la
laïcité ils ne sont pas d'accord sur la
police ne sont pas d'accord finalement
rien par conséquent deux coalitions sont
devant nous mais le premier parti celui
qui a un programme cohérent et qui fait
10 9% c'est le rassemblement je rappelle
qu on a fait quand même une progression
d'un million 250 mille anonymes est-ce
que vous n'oubliez pas et l'air quand
même c'est pas frustrant d'arriver donc
justement en deuxième à l'élection
présidentielle et vous êtes derrière
ensemble la nuque de coalition où le dit
mais également et l'air en nombre de
sièges non mais ça c'est vous qui le
dites les résultats que nous avons c'est
que le rassemblement national est au
second tour dans 208 circonscription
parmi lesquels nous sommes en tête dans
plus de cent d'entre elles par
conséquent nous avons mathématiquement
en théorie comme le font les autres 208
député du rassemblement final qui
peuvent faire une entrée fracassante
marine le pen dit ce matin que vous
visiez plusieurs dizaines de députés
vous visez combien on parle plutôt
peut-être deux dizaines ça ce n'est pas
ce statisticien moi j'espère que le plus
grand nombre d'entre eux feront leur
entrée dans l'assemblée nationale nous
avons des talents au sein du
rassemblement national qui sont parfois
méconnus en tout état de cause je crois
que le fait d'avoir un groupe
parlementaire le fait d'avoir des moyens
15 et donc habilité 15 députés ça c'est
déjà extrêmement important et là encore
c'est ça démontre à la progression du
rassemblement social dans le pays
maintenant vous le connaissez on a un
mode de scrutin qui est quand même très
particulier
la france est la lanterne rouge de
l'union européen par des parties qui
appelle au barrage contre vous oui
qu'est-ce que ça change pour vous un
groupe ben vous le savez comme moi même
mieux que moi un groupe ce sont des
moyens un groupe c'est une visibilité un
groupe c'est un staff comme on dit deux
personnes qui peuvent travailler sur les
textes par conséquent on démontrera et
on démontre à nouveau notre progression
vous l'avez dit madame nous avons des
barrages et j'ai entendu madame bornes
expliqué qu'elle voterait voile appelés
à voter pour des candidats de lannux
comme monsieur roussel ce qui prouve une
chose c'est que 1 jean luc mélenchon ne
sera pas premier ministre et que deux la
nuque ne fait peur à personne pas même à
emmanuel macron puisque eux mêmes
appellent à voter pour des listes anti
républicaine elle vous faites ça vous
fait oui qui va d'abord de me fait peur
oui c'est maintenant la limite ben pas
du tout la même passion la réalité nous
avons un mouvement
qui
voter est appelé à voter pour emmanuel
macron à la présidence mais sur l'anus
vous fait peur puisqu'elle
fait peur pourquoi on a un mouvement qui
insultent les fonctionnaires d'état
notamment les policiers en expliquant
que les la police tue c'est à dire les
institutions on a un mouvement qui
insultent les fonctionnaires d'état de
l'éducation nationale vous savez comme
moi que mes jeux préférés on dans le
pays juste le tarif de tourisme nous
avons dans le pays un enseignant sur
deux qui saute sans censure sur la
laïcité et parallèlement lannux va
manifester que les islamistes comme
c'était le cas le 10 novembre 2000 âmes
donc oui j'ai peur de lannux donc vous
dites aux militants et rennes ne surtout
pas voter la nuque
jeudi à mille temps derniers demandent à
l'éviter alors de voter plutôt en son
nom mais sans mener dans ce car vous
n'êtes pas si c'est un ensemble face à
la nuit
second tour entre la nuque et en sortent
bien évidemment que nous n'appellerons à
voter ni pour les uns ni pour les autres
ni pour les destructeurs d'en haut le
camp des élites avec emmanuel macron ni
pour les indigéniste d'en bas qui
détruisent aussi la république et la
france vous avez quand même un
militez-vous à la france insoumise où
vous êtes même présenter aux
législatives pour la france insoumise
vous parlez quand même comme ça de la
france est soumise aujourd'hui vous ne
dites pas un chapeau l'artiste à jean
luc mélenchon qui a réussi à attirer
qu'en même temps on épingle du jeu c'est
un cartel de partis comme jean luc
mélenchon sait le faire oui il ya eu un
réellement changement chez la france est
soumise absolument totale d'ailleurs le
maître à penser de jean luc mélenchon
monsieur henri pena ruiz a quitté jean
luc mélenchon monsieur kuzmanovic
conseiller historique a quitté la france
soumise moi même j'ai quitté les trois
quarts de l'équipe de jean luc mélenchon
en 2007 ou quitter jean luc mélenchon
pourquoi parce que sur la laïcité ils
ont abandonné est manifeste et
islamiques sur l'europe maintenant aubry
souhaite la sauver vous en souvenez dans
ce débat où elle a sorti une bouteille
d'oxygène pour sauver l'europe et moi je
me souviens que jean luc mélenchon
faisait des tracts à destination des
policiers sur leurs conditions de
travail aux pompiers aux gendarmes
fonctionnaires aujourd'hui il n'est plus
question la france insoumise que de
violence policière par conséquent le
changement radical c'est pas moi c'est
jean luc mélenchon n'a vous dites c'est
lui qui a changé mais quand vous voyez
tout de même la réussite de cette union
de la gauche est ce que vous ne vous
dites pas qu'il faudrait faire une union
de la droite met enfin en réalité c'est
pas du tout un succès pourquoi la nuque
aujourd'hui elle fait 25,5 quand vous
cumulez les résultats aux législatives
de la nuque c'est à dire des parties ses
25 points 5 aucune progression avec la
nuque par ailleurs prendre à elle seule
étiquette commune barrail une étiquette
par ailleurs je vais vous répondre tout
de suite ils sont à réaliser ensemble
c'est une baisse de 4 points par rapport
au score cumulé présidentielle donc tout
ce cirque médiatique
en réalité ça fait pschitt par ailleurs
sur l'étiquette mais ils l'ont annoncé
eux mêmes dès le lendemain de l'élection
ils feront chacun un groupe il ya un
groupe comme une île en groupe ils ont
formé annabelle fait auparavant un
groupe qui associe aussi un groupe
socialiste moi je me souviens de
monsieur fort
lors des législatives de 2007 il
expliqué qu' il n'était pas l'
opposition emmanuel macron le voilà
aujourd'hui avec l'extrême gauche anti
sioniste en expliquant qu'il avec
mélenchon tout ça n'est pas claire ce
qui est certain c'est que la seule
opposition emmanuel macron la seule qui
a été cohérente et courageuse elle
s'appelle marine le pen tam donc il faut
pas il faut pas d'union de la droite
pour vous mais voyez-vous marine le pen
ne croient plus dans le clivage gauche
droite moi même je ne crois plus au
clivage gauche droite il ya le camp du
peuple avec marine le pen il ya le camp
des élites elles deux les gars chez avec
monsieur macron moi vous savez en ayant
passé douze années aux côtés de jean-luc
mélenchon je ne me reconnais pas
personnellement dans tous ces concepts
d'union des droites est-ce que c'est
donc une satisfaction pour vous de voir
le candidat qui prenait lui l'union des
droites eric zemmour pour reconquête ne
pas parvenir à se qualifier pour le
deuxième tour on peut pas je suis pas
gilbert collard qui souhaitent le
malheur des autres moi je ne souhaite
pas le malheur pour eric zemmour enfin
une satisfaction est la même en tout
état de cause il est bien évident que le
peuple les ouvriers votent pour marine
le pen les dom-tom vote pour marine le
pen bref ces zones périphériques se
peuplent ces ouvriers ses salariés ses
intérimaires tous ces français qui
souffrent vote pour marine le pen vote
pour le camp du peuple et je l'espère
voteront davantage dimanche prochain car
voyez vous envoyer une centaine de
députés ou des dizaines de députés à
rennes ça change absolument tout de même
qu'à ce qu'il n'y a pas une satisfaction
à voir reconquête qui est de tenter de
faire une alliance avec vous vous l'avez
refusé par rapport à ce qu'avait pu vous
dire eric zemmour qui disait que vous
n'arrêtez pas de perdre bien finalement
ne pas se qualifier au deuxième tour et
l'ensemble des candidats reconquête qui
font de même je me suis dit dan en
gérance en matière d'international je
vais pas commenter
les affaires internes de reconquête ce
qui est certain c'est que je suis très
heureux que leur assemblée nationale
soit un parti qui est progressait de 1
million de salaire justement le parti
oui justement quelle organisation pour
la suite du rassemblement national
marine le pen présidente du du groupe à
l'assemblée nationale a priori jordan
bar de la rue qui restera président du
parti c'est ça que vous voyez écoutez on
n'en sait rien pour l'instant ne au
second tour nous n'avons pas encore de
députés puisque nous les aurons dimanche
prochain si nos électeurs se déplacent
par ailleurs effectivement nous avons un
congrès à la rentrée ou certainement il
y aura une organisation comme dans tous
les partis les militants vont voter pour
les instances et c'est moi du personnel
je ne suis pas membre du rassemblement
national j'ai fondé les localistes avec
hervé juvin comme thierry mariani à la
droite populaire par conséquent ce n'est
pas moi qui vous expliquer ce qui va se
passer en interne au rassemblement
national tout ce que j'espère c'est que
je salue bien évidemment marine le pen
qui est vrai rita blement a incarné le
camp du peuple vous souvenez une
alliance de montebourg à zemmour c'est à
dire que l a vu ce qui se passait dans
le monde à la vue ce qui se passait
entre montagnes a vu ce qui se passait y
compris en afrique ou en asie où la
gauche la droite ça n'existe absolument
faux gâché son étiquette du président du
rassemblement national c'est nécessaire
pour je crois dans la gare de lors des
élections présidentielles le fait que
marine le pen soit au dessus du parti et
même des partis puisque il y avait une
alliance de plusieurs partis c'était
bénéfique et que ça a été bénéfique dans
les iob puisqu'elle a fait un record je
rappelle quand même 13 millions de voix
contre emmanuel macron contre la
retraite à 65 ans rédigé par mckinsey
qui sera géré par blackrock nous
continuerons combat d'opposition car
véritablement la seule opposition c'est
marine le pen monsieur jadot appelé
voter pour monsieur macro second tour
monsieur mélenchon monsieur faure tous
ces gens là sont en réalité les nouveaux
chiens de garde de l'oligarchie puisque
ce sont eux qui ont porté emmanuel
macron au pouvoir lors de la dernière
élection présidentielle moi sur jordan
bardet l'alleud le président par intérim
de du rassemblement national ce qui
ferait lui un bon candidat à l'élection
présidentielle
écoutez nous verrons bien moi ce qui
m'importe c'est que d'ici à 2027 il n'y
aura qu'une seule élection les
européennes c'est à dire que le vote de
dimanche est extrêmement important pour
porter la voix de l'opposition moi j'ai
eu à travailler avec jordan bardella je
dois dire que c'est quelqu'un
d'extraordinaire qui percute à toutes
les idées qui est très dynamique et qui
effectivement fait son rôle à son jeune
âge de prison deux parties et marine le
pen comme le disait et frère tout à
l'heure on ne sait plus très bien sur
quel pied danser en ce qui concerne une
possible prochaine candidature à la
présidentielle vous la voyez évidemment
est ce que vous pensez qu'elle a envie
d'y aller ou c'est une page qui se
tourne comme elle l'avait laissé
entendre août et nous verrons bien ça ne
remplit pas le frigo des français que de
commenter cela classe est important pour
le parti d'avoir des personnes ont parlé
à liv l'internation la capitale même si
la question c'est de savoir si marine le
pen incarne le rassemblement du peuple
incontestablement l'a prouvé lors des
dernières élections présidentielles pas
ya deux ans il ya juste quelques jours
avec 13 millions de voix d'où je pense
qu'elle est parfaitement compétente pour
le faire par ailleurs ce qui me frustre
et ce qui m'inquiète c'est le bilan des
manuels macron on a 12 millions de
personnes qui n'arrivent pas à se
chauffer dans ce pays on estime qu'il y
en aura 24 millions on à 52% abstentions
trois français sur 10 qui refusent
d'aller se faire soigner pour des
raisons alors justement escale et quand
j'ai lancé à rennes l'important est ce
que réside la représentation n'est pas
assez saine lors de cette élection c'est
à dire c'est parce que c'est mon curseur
on a eu la jeune scène ah ben vous savez
je vous le dit tout à l'heure nous
sommes la lanterne rouge va pas le
changer abbassi puisque emmanuel macron
voulait le changer la 1ère fois
que je vais d'après ce que je lis
justement c'est impossible sauf si nos
électeurs se déplacent et
finalement diminue et amoindrissent les
pleins pouvoirs et indemnités à rennes
se serait malsain
une idée là j'ai pris sur moi je vous
dis une seule chose à vous suffirait
pour faire un groupe non mais que le que
le mode de scrutin soit inefficace tout
le monde le sait autour de cette table
quand marine le pen fait 42% aux
élections présidentielles et qu'elle a
huit députés c'est juste intolérables
donc évidemment que ce mode de scrutin
ne représente pas les français moi ce
que j'essaie de vous dire c'est que la
situation sociale est catastrophique
dans ce pays et que si nous avons nous
n'avons pas une opposition ferme et
cohérente à emmanuel macron avec marine
le pen effectivement nous allons droit
vers de me des moments peut être violent
on verra vous nous dire si vous êtes
candidat aux européennes c'est une
élection qui a l'air de vous intéresser
vous reviendrez nous le dire merci en
tout cas grec était avec nous sur le
plateau d'auditions publiques merci tam
merci petit boucher merci yves on vous
reçoit en asie la prochaine fois merci
d'avoir été avec nous pour présenter les
enjeux pour chaque candidat on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine au
lendemain du second tour des
législatives
et alors suspense d'ici là bonne semaine
[Musique]